faire de notre société une société
pleinement inclusive telle est
l'ambition qui guide l'action du
gouvernement en matière de handicap
depuis désormais quatre années le sens
de cette action qui vise à améliorer le
quotidien des personnes en situation de
handicap à leur donner la possibilité de
vivre une citoyenneté comme les autres
s'inscrit dans un projet plus large
d'égalité des chances de justice
d'équité de liberté d'agir et de choisir
ses principes républicains ne saurait
s'épanouir dans un système autre que
celui de la solidarité
la proposition de loi portant diverses
mesures de justice sociale vient
justement remettre en cause le coeur de
nos principes de solidarité et de
redistribution
je souhaite le rappeler car je pense que
c'est fondamental
le fait que la solidarité nationale
s'appuie sur la solidarité familiale
pour adapter son soutien pour personnes
précaires constitue la base même de
notre système socio-fiscal un système où
le foyer est considérée comme la cellule
protectrice dans l'esprit même du code
civil qui consacre à l'article 220 la
solidarité entre époux un système qui
s'attache à assurer en permanence une
redistribution juste est dédié en
priorité à la protection des plus
fragiles
cette juste articulation entre
solidarité nationale les solidarités
conjugale ne peut fonctionner que si les
ressources du foyer des bénéficiaires
sont prises en compte
c'est dans cette philosophie que la loi
du 3 de jean 30 juin 1975 a créé
l'allocation adulte handicapé pour
assurer des conditions de vie dignes aux
personnes en situation de handicap dans
les ressources sont les plus faibles sur
l'ensemble des pans de l'action publique
le gouvernement a fait de l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat des personnes en
situation de handicap une priorité du
quinquennat
à ce titre rappelons que 51 milliards
sont consacrés actuellement chaque année
à l'amélioration et la simplification du
quotidien des personnes en situation de
handicap
cela représente 2,2 pour cent de notre
pib
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés aah
représente à elle seule 11 milliard cent
millions de budget en 2020 les deux
vagues de revalorisation exceptionnelle
conduite en 2018 et en 2019 ont entraîné
une augmentation d'environ 775 millions
de dépenses annuelles
à cela s'ajoutent des avancées majeures
en termes d'accès au droit
l'allongement de la durée de trois des
droits
l'abandon de l'obligation de faire
valoir le droit à la spa et le maintien
automatique des droits acquis depuis au
début de la crise sanitaire
nous pouvons collectivement en être fier
s'agissant précisément de l'allocation
adulte handicapé maintenant en avril
cette allocation s'établissait à 810
euros par mois nous l'avons porté à 903
euros par mois en avril 2019
cet engagement du président de la
république représente ainsi une
augmentation de pouvoir d'achat de près
de 12% pour les 1,2 million de personnes
bénéficiaires de la hache
cet investissement massif est estimé à
plus de 2 milliards sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat
des chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes je ne
crois pas que l'on puisse remettre en
cause la place du handicap au sein des
priorités du gouvernement et du
quinquennat néanmoins ces actions ont
toujours été menés dans le but de faire
des personnes en situation de handicap
des citoyens à part entière des citoyens
qui ont les mêmes droits les mêmes
devoirs des citoyens qui font pleinement
partie de notre système de solidarité de
notre système fiscal de notre système
redistributif des citoyens qui
aujourd'hui contribuent à cette notion
de partage des ressources et des charges
au sein d'une famille au sein d'un
couple
toutefois dans cette logique de droit
commun nous avons voulu assurer la prise
en compte des spécificités des personnes
en situation de handicap
il ne s'agit pas de créer un régime
dérogatoire vous savez à quel point j'ai
à coeur d'inclure les personnes
situation de handicap mais bien d'avoir
un système juste et adaptée à chacun
permettez-moi de revenir sur ces
mécanismes certes complexe mais
important pour prendre en compte la
situation de handicap
selon trois objectifs spécifiques tout
d'abord du fait de l'éloignement à
l'emploi pour certaines personnes en
situation d'handicap
le montant de l'allocation est beaucoup
plus élevée que celle par exemple du rsa
903 euros paula h environ 565 pour le
rsa son fonctionnement est également
fait de telle sorte de favoriser le
cumul d'un emploi et de la hache
car rappelons que dans un couple dans 35
% des cas c'est la personne en situation
de handicap qui travaillent en effet le
plafond pour percevoir la hache
lorsqu'on est en couple et de 3000 euros
si c'est la personne handicapée qui
travaillent et de 2200 70 euros si c'est
son conjoint qui travaille en raison
d'un abattement supérieur à 50 % sur les
revenus du bénéficiaire et de 28 pour
cent de celui de son conjoint
par ailleurs les abattements retenus sur
les ressources d'activité pour le calcul
de la hache sont bien plus élevés que
pour toutes les autres allocations que
l'on parle du conjoint ou du
bénéficiaire
toujours pour favoriser l'incitation à
la reprise d'activité
la reconnaissance de la spécificité liée
à la situation de handicap
passé également par une exonération
d'assiette fiscale pour la hache de fait
une demi part fiscale supplémentaire est
attribuée au foyer avec une personne en
situation de handicap à laquelle
s'ajoute une exonération sur la taxe
d'habitation et la taxe foncière
il est normal que ces règles existent
comme je les dis elle vise à permettre
une meilleure intégration des personnes
dans l'emploi cet accès à l'emploi est
l'un des piliers de notre politique en
matière de handicap
la présente proposition de loi est au
delà de ces considérations surtout
révélatrice d'un appel des associations
concernant la situation des femmes en
situation de handicap victimes de
violence est sous emprise de leur
conjoint jeté hier matin à l'occasion de
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes dans un centre d'hébergement
d'urgence qui favorise l'accès au droit
et la mise en protection
une femme qui ont subi des violences et
je suis extrêmement sensible
vous connaissez madame la présidente de
la délégation aux droits des femmes
madame annick billon mon engagement sur
ce sujet que j'ai rappelé lors de la
table ronde sur les violences faites aux
femmes fin 2018 et je sais que nous
partageons ce combat mais nous devons
aller plus loin et donner une réponse
concrète et opérationnelle
et je vous remercie par cette
proposition de loi de me donner
l'opportunité de répondre à ces femmes
comme je lé rappeler actuellement lorsqu
une séparation est signalé à une caf
elle rentre dans les situations
prioritaires que la caf s'engage à
traiter en dix jours au plus tard
ce mécanisme nécessitent non point un
accompagnement individuel des femmes
violentées pour leur permettre de se
loger et de sortir de leur entrée de
l'emprise de leurs conjoints violents
afin de proposer des mesures destinées à
améliorer le repérage et
l'accompagnement des femmes des travaux
sur trois territoires d'expérimentation
appuyé par le groupe de travail handicap
mise en place dans le cadre du grenelle
des violences à l'encontre des femmes
devront permettre de déterminer puis
expérimenté un cadre prévoyant notamment
une plus grande réactivité du montant de
la hache aux situations de violence
conjugale les premiers travaux les
premiers jalons de ces travaux ont été
lancés hier avec l'aide du département
de la gironde
je souhaite que l'ensemble des parties
prenantes puissent y trouver leur place
associations acteurs du territoire bien
sûr élus locaux et bien sûr les
sénateurs et sénatrices concernés
notamment alain cazabonne nathalie
delattre florence lassarade pour ne
citer qu'eux c'est avec vous que ces
politiques se construiront la
proposition de loi que nous examinions
pose de réelles questions sur le sens
donné à nos politiques publiques et sur
le chemin qui nous reste à parcourir
pour améliorer le quotidien des
personnes en situation de handicap
les amendements du rapporteur mouillés
ont permis la correction de l'écriture
initial de la proposition de loi en
rétablissant l'existence d'un plafond de
ressources en respect des principes de
solidarité pour lesquelles je nous
sommes tous attachés et j'ai pu le
mesurer lors de nos échanges
la réécriture de l'article 3 concentre
donc sauf ceux sur la neutralisation des
ressources du conjoint dans le calcul
des droits à la
la dea conjugale isation de
l'éligibilité de lâches
à ceci près qu'en raison des effets
négatifs induits par ce mode de calcul
article 3 bis créer un nouveau droit
d'option pendant 10 ans pour les
bénéficiaires actuels à conserver des
règles de conjugale isation des
ressources en plus de renchérir le coût
de la mesure qui atteint 730 millions
cette disposition ajoute à la complexité
du recours à la location
elle crée pour les personnes une
incertitude forte et des difficultés à
projeter leur pouvoir d'achat
cette mesure ne relève pas de la justice
sociale à ne créer qu'un dispositif à
deux vitesses aux règles toujours plus
compliquées alors même que l'effort
devrait être porté sur l'amélioration du
recours au droit et la simplification
des parcours de vie l'exemple le plus
parlant concerne les couples des
travailleurs en esat pour qu il ad
conjugale isation entraîne une perte
nette de 400 euros en moyenne
comment pourront-ils actionné leur droit
d'option comment les professionnels qui
les accompagnent auront dorénavant la
charge de les conseiller en la matière
ne créons pas de complexité dans les
parcours des personnes attachons-nous
plutôt à simplifier leur accès aux
dispositifs conçus pour les accompagner
et les soutenir
depuis la loi de 2005 la création de la
prestation de compensation du handicap
assure une prise en compte de la
situation de handicap de façon
individualisée et sans condition de
ressources
cette prestation elle vise à compenser
les besoins d'autonomie des personnes
avec de l'aide humaine de l'aide
technique de l'aménagement du logement
de transport des aides spécifiques en
nous avons 4 consacré 2,6 milliards de
dépenses publiques en cofinancement avec
les départements chef de file des
politiques de solidarité
ainsi un tiers des personnes qui
touchent la hache peu avant a menti en
moyenne 500 euros de plus avec la
prestation de compensation du handicap
la pch et la hache répondent donc à des
objectifs différents la première vient
compenser la situation de handicap de
façon individus
en assurant les moyens de l'autonomie
comme son nom l'indiqué alors que la
seconde assure un revenu digne pour les
personnes à faibles ressources
suivant cette idée et comme je l'avais
annoncé lors de mon audition le 18
février dernier
je vous propose donc une mission puisse
formuler des propositions
s'agissant de la simplification et de
l'articulation des dispositifs existants
afin d'assurer un soutien plus efficace
et équitable aux personnes en situation
de handicap
ces réflexions nécessite un temps plus
long que celui offert par le débat
parlementaire
c'est un sujet qui mérite un travail de
fond un travail approfondi et concertée
je crois qu'il nous faut entamer un
travail pose et qui nous permettent de
réexaminer ces différents dispositifs
existants leur articulation avec la
prestation de compensation du handicap
ainsi que leur place dans notre système
de solidarité en regard notamment de la
création de la 5ème branche que tous les
parlementaires mobilisent dans le débat
enfin sur l'article 4 qui propose de
relever l'âge maximum pour bénéficier de
la paie sage de 60 ans à au moins 5 65
ans vous comprendrez bien mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
représentants de la chambre haute de
notre parlement
garant des intérêts des territoires que
nous ne pouvons prendre de telles
dispositions sans avoir mené des travaux
concerter avec les présidents des
conseils départementaux avec lesquels
nous sommes en coresponsabilité
car rappelons qu'une telle augmentation
générerait un coût supplémentaire
d'environ 20 millions d'euros
pour toutes ces raisons je ne suis pas
favorable à cette proposition de loi tel
qu amendé par la commission des affaires
sociales je vous remercie
jeudi débattre à nouveau de la hache par
souci de concision
car ce débat et plus justement une
occasion de clarifier notre système de
protection sociale
là des congés lisation de la hache est
en effet tout sauf une mesure technique
elle tient aux lignes dans le code de la
sécurité sociale
mais c'est une ligne de code fondamental
dans notre logiciel de solidarité en
rejetant la proposition de loi analogues
de nos collègues du groupe crc en
octobre 2018
le sénat n'avait d'ailleurs fait que de
défendre logique d'ensemble selon
laquelle nos prestations sociales
prennent en compte la composition d'un
foyer donné c'est cette logique
qui fait l'objet du débat que les
derniers mois ont été ré d'une lumière
complètement nouvelle mais partout
plutôt de la demande qui nous est
adressé avant de remonter aux grands
principes
le montant de la hache est calculée en
tenant compte des revenus du
bénéficiaire et de ceux de son conjoint
lorsqu'il est en couple lesquels ne le
doivent pas dépasser un certain plafond
qui prend par ailleurs en considération
le nombre d'enfants part conséquente
elle bénéficia de la hache qui
s'installerait en couple avec quelqu'un
dont les revenus additionnels aux chiens
dépasserait le plafond explique ces
perdrait le bénéfice de son allocation
les associations de personnes
handicapées appelle cela le prix de
l'amour
par parenthèse c'est une vue un peu
réductrice qui avait aussi des personnes
handicapées dont les revenus personnels
sont au dessus du plafond et qui
deviennent bénéficier de la hache
on s'installe à en couple avec quelqu'un
dont les revenus sont si faibles que le
plafond applicable aux couples restent à
franchir
reste que la majorité des personnes dont
l'âge c'est supprimer ou écrêté du seul
fait de leur statut conjugal éprouve une
frustration bien compréhensible à 6 ils
voient leurs aspirations à l'autonomie
brutalement censure et peut-être même la
dépendance alors conjointe pour les
dépenses quotidiennes lancera-t-elle
plus supportable si elle ne leur
semblait pas imposé par l'entêtement
inhérents à la pression d'une règle
administrative il faut encore pour
comprendre le sentiment accorder un peu
d'attention à une autre catégorie
d'arguments les plus jeunes générations
mes chers collègues aspire à davantage
d'autonomie financière dans leur couple
le phénomène est d'autant plus sensible
chez les jeunes femmes chez les jeunes
femmes d'une manière générale car il
gagne toujours en moyenne moins que
leurs conjoints masculin alors qu'elles
sont désormais en moyenne plus diplômées
plus diplômés
chez les jeunes femmes en situation de
handicap en particulier car elles sont
hélas plus souvent victimes de violences
conjugales
comme l'a montré un récent rapport de
notre délégation aux droits des femmes
jusqu'à présent cette demande se heurter
un argument assez simple tâche n'est pas
une prestation de compensation du
handicap mais un minimum social et la
sûreté nationale qui s'exerce à travers
un minimum social passe après la société
familiale quand
lise le code civil en conséquence de
quoi ce sont les revenus du ménage qui
doit être pris en compte pour calculer
la prestation mais cet argument en
réalité est de moins en moins
convaincant car ce qui confère à la
hache son caractère mai 2009 sociale
c'est essentiellement ce mécanisme l'âge
est une prestation versée sous
conditions de ressources de manière
différentiel afin de porter le niveau de
vie du bénéficiaire à un minimum de
subsistance
une fois prise en compte toutes les
ressources dont il dispose
elle est en outre financé par l'état et
n'a donc pas de caractère indemnitaire
l'achat cependant toujours été un
minimum social d'un type un peu
particulier
la chef des ressources présent compter
le mode de calcul de la prestation sont
plus avantageux que ceux des autres
minima sociaux et son montant est
relativement plus élevé ce montant a
surtout été au fortement revalorisée à
deux reprises en 2008 et en 2010 est
parlée président nicolas sarkozy
emmanuel macron or comment justifier de
telles augmentations de la seule à h et
non des autres prestations assurant un
minimum de subsistance
c'est les plus généreuses forcément
l'âge on pense quelque chose
et quoi sinon un éloignement de l'emploi
a pu tableau handicap
c'est d'ailleurs le sens des critères
exigés des personnes dont le taux
d'incapacité est compris entre 50 et 80%
et sillage compense quelque chose propre
à la personne on ne saurait indexé son
montant sur des variables qui lui sont
exogènes la clarification des termes du
débat ne pouvait venir que d'une
manifestation de volonté politique
ils font donc souligner celle dû prendre
la république exprimé lors de la
conférence nationale du handicap de
février 2019
lui-même a retiré la hache du chantier
relatif au run universel d'activité une
telle décision confirme que l'ach a
moins à voir avec un minimum social
qu'avec une prestation de compensation
et ouvre ainsi la voie à l'accord de la
demande sociale qui nous est faite avec
les principes généraux de notre système
d'intervention
cette question réglée que penser du
texte qui nous est transmis
la commission ne pouvait hélas pas le
voter en état d'une part car il avait il
aurait eu en dépit de son titre
des conséquences a juste là des
conjugale isation ferait certes un grand
nombre de ménages gagnant environ 196
1000 mais aussi 44 il ménage perdant
parmi ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
dont le conjoint valide a peu ou pas de
revenus d'autre part la rédaction de
l'article 3 conduisait à supprimer tous
les plafonds de cumul de la prestation
avec les ressources personnelles du
bénéficiaire
avec pour effet d'attribuer la hache à
taux plein à tous se remplissant les
conditions nécessaires l'adresse en
estime d'ailleurs le coup à 20 milliards
d'euros
la commission a par conséquent accepter
la déclenche des conjugale isation mais
rétabli le plafond de cumul entre les
ressources personnelles du bénéficiaire
et le montant de la prestation et pour
éviter de pénaliser 44 mille personnes
elle a aménagé un mec qu'a mécanisme
transitoire simple permettant
bénéficiaires pendant dix ans de
continuer à percevoir la hache selon les
modalités de calcul actuel reste des
questions que la commission ne pouvait
trancher seule au détour d'une
proposition de loi en cours de navette
d'abord la cohérence générale des
principes n'est certes pas encore totale
si l'on accepte d'y voir une prestation
compensant les moindre chance de
percevoir des revenus d'activité et de
suivre une progression de carrière
normale on devait considérer lundi lisa
sion complète de la hache et donc
éventuellement revoir son mode de calcul
c'était tout au fond l'hypothèse faisant
le plus grand nombre de perdants
ensuite nous savons bien que le pilotage
et la prestation est difficile ce que la
cour des comptes a montré dans un
rapport de novembre 2019
la procédure est complexe plus clair
pour les demandeurs la connaissance des
bénéficiaires suffisantes et l'appareil
statistique et peu réactif la commission
l'a constaté en essayant en vain
d'évaluer les conséquences du texte plus
finement que ne l'a fait la direction
statistique des ministères sociaux
par conséquent la dépense croatie
rapidement les 560 millions d'euros de
la dea conjugale isation sont aussi a
rapporté 11 milliards d'euros que
représente la hache aujourd'hui en
hausse de 2 milliards d'euros depuis
quatre ans or il se trouve que nos
systèmes de position sociale s'est
enrichie rousselet l'année dernière
d'une cinquième branche de sica et et
social
consacrée au soutien à l'autonomie dans
la gestion a été confiée à la scène et
ça le gouvernement nous l'a assez dit
son périmètre n'est pas définitif
voyons voyons ici l'occasion de repenser
notre système d'intervention pour le
rendre plus efficace et plus efficient
il serait ainsi cohérent comme le
proposait le rapport de laurent vacher
17 en dernier d'admettre que la hache
n'est pas un pur minimum social c'est
écrit et de se poser la question de son
éventuel transfert je dis bien un
éventuel transfert à la branche
autonomie il faudra alors sans doute
pensé son articulation avec la pch où le
régime des pensions d'invalidité dont la
hache n'est jamais que le pendant hors
couverture assurantielle un membre un
fin sur l'article 4 qui relève de 60 à
65 ans la barrière d'âge pour solliciter
la prestation de compensation du
handicap
c'est une idée ancienne constaté mme la
ministre avec les départements que celle
de supprimer toutes les barrières d'âge
puisqu'elle date de la grande loi de 11
février 2005
sa mise en oeuvre a depuis toujours été
ajournée j'avais naguère proposé de
supprimer la seconde guerre d'âge celle
de 75 ans pour solliciter la pch
proposition qui est devenue la loi du 7
mars 2020 il est désormais temps d'aller
plus loin en élargissant la couverture
des besoins des bénéficiaires de la pch
jusqu'à leurs 65 ans il faudra ensuite
s'atteler sérieusement au
décloisonnement des politiques destinées
au handicap d'une part et odorante âge
d'autre part dans une logique de
parcours de vie c'est encore tout
l'enjeu de la branche autonomie qui ne
pourra rester en un chantier trop
longtemps car si nous discutons
aujourd'hui de cet exo loi cdu a
justement parce qu'elle le texte sur le
lait branche autonomie n'a pas été
clairement défini et c'est pourquoi je
vous invite mes chers collègues adapté
pour commencer la promotion de loi dans
la rédaction résultant des travaux de la
commission des affaires sociales je
remercie pour votre attention
tendre vers une société plus inclusive
est une des priorités absolues
les 51 milliards d'euros qui sont
consacrés chaque année soit 2 2% du pib
le démontre l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés représente à elle seule 11
milliards d'euros en
1020 la france à ce titre fait figure
d'exception puisque seulement très peu
de pays au monde sont dotées d'un
système de prestations de même type
je veux également souligné l'action du
gouvernement en la matière qui traduit
notamment par l'augmentation de 100
euros par mois de la hache pour 1,2
million de bénéficiaires ce qui
représente une augmentation de pouvoir
d'achat de près de deux courses 12 % ce
qui n'était pas arrivé depuis près de
onze ans le texte que nous examinons
propose dans la version transmise à
notre assemblée de supprimer la prise en
compte des revenus du conjoint dans le
calcul de l'allocation adulte handicapé
de la majoration de son plafonnement et
de reporter la barrière d'âge de 60 ans
pour solliciter le bénéfice de la
prestation de compensation du handicap
en supprimant initialement la notion de
plafond et en enlevant et ressources du
partenaire l'adoption de la proposition
de loi pourrait entraîner 20 milliards
d'euros de dépenses nouvelles sur
proposition du rapporteur la commission
a réintégré la notion de plafond portant
son coût à 560 millions d'euros afin
d'éviter que cette ppl ne crée des
foyers défavorisés il conviendrait
d'aligner les plafonds pour une personne
isolée sur le plafond pour un couple ce
qui représenterait en réalité une
dépense totale de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros
il s'agit d'une dépense conséquente
compte tenu de la situation économique
actuelle et des efforts consentis par la
nation pour protéger nos concitoyens et
les secteurs les plus impactés par la
crise sanitaire le mécanisme transitoire
définie à l'article 3 bis 3 bis fait
suite à un amendement du rapporteur
juger de manière assez surprenante je
joue là vous recevable financièrement
malgré un coût de plusieurs centaines de
millions ce mécanisme créerait une
inégalité entre les allocataires qui
continuerait à bénéficier de la hache et
d'autres qui postérieurement à l'entrée
en vigueur de la proposition de loi ne
seraient plus éligibles
alors même que leur situation serait
identique une telle mesure nous semble
donc aller à l'encontre de nos règles
constitutionnelles notamment d'égalité
des droits
plus largement encore bien que nous
partageons l'objectif de mieux
accompagner et soutenir les personnes en
situation de handicap
les mesures prévues par cette
proposition de loi comporte un certain
nombre de difficultés
lâche vise à assurer des conditions de
vie dignes aux personnes en situation de
handicap dans les ressources sont les
plus faibles
il est donc conçu comme un minima social
pour permettre à nos concitoyens d'avoir
un revenu décent pour vivre en
complément d'autres sources de revenus
éventuels
à cet égard la fixation d'un montant
plus élevé de l'âge pour que pour le rsa
socle et les abattements fiscaux
correspondent bien à la prise en cours
de la spécificité du handicap et non à
une logique de compensation
or de fait ce texte opère un changement
de cap sur la nature même de la hache et
plus généralement remet en cause un des
piliers de notre pote notre politique
familiale
rappelons que la solidarité nationale
qui s'appuie sur la solidarité conjugale
n'est pas une spécificité de la hache
mais concerne tous les minima sociaux en
vertu de l'obligation entre époux ainsi
la hache repose sur les principes
d'équité et de partage des charges entre
les membres du foyer contrairement aux
prestations universelles avec la d
conjugale isation de la hache
nous risquons d'ouvrir la brèche pour
d'autres minima sociaux et de modifier
profondément notre solidarité familiale
que deviendrait le quotient familial où
l'ennemi par quid du rsa à cet égard
rappelons que le coût
d'individualisation totale du rsa avait
été estimé à près de 9 milliards d'euros
en 2016 des congés égaliser la hache
aggraverait les inégalités sociales
puisque la réforme en l'état contre et
des perdants parmi les ménages les plus
modestes et des gagnants parmi les
ménages les plus aisés
si cette ppl se veut être l'étendard
pour le soutien aux personnes en
situations les plus difficiles
la réalité n'est pas si clair je
prendrai deux exemples pour illustrer
mon propos
un allocataire qui travaillent 05 smic
avec un conjoint rémunéré deux smic
bénéficierait d'un gain net allant de
320 à 720 euros
a contrario l'individualisation total de
la prestation serait défavorable pour
les couples dans la locataire aah est
aujourd'hui le seul à percevoir un
revenu d'activité avec un manque à
gagner pouvant aller jusqu'à 550 euros
pour un allocataire au smic
au total ce sont 44 mille bénéficiaires
qui travaillent et sont en couple avec
un conjoint dont les revenus sont
modestes ou inexistant qui verraient
leurs allocations dit
minuit le fait de travailler dès
favoriserait donc un certain nombre de
bénéficiaires al'inverse de la mission
initiale de la hache
enfin l'article 4 de la proposition de
loi prévoit de relever l'âge maximum
pour bénéficier de la prestation de
compensation du handicap de 60 ans à au
moins 65 ans chers collègues
ce dispositif n'est pas anodin pour les
finances de nos départements
l'état ne compense qu'à hauteur de 30 à
40% des dépenses liées à celles-ci d'une
telle mesure
bien qu'intéressante sur le fond mais
ces sites une concertation et une
co-construction avec les départements
qui dépasse largement le cadre contraint
d'une ppl cet âge limite ajouterait même
un poids administratif pour les
départements par le basculement des
bénéficiaires de l'apa vers la pch et
une complexité pour les usagers et leur
est donc comme cela a été rappelé par la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale
nous porterons donc un amendement visant
à privilégier la révélation de ces
tâches tous les cinq ans par décret en
tonneau compte des évolutions
démographiques des besoins de nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap et
après une nécessaire concertation avec
les départements le gestionnaire restera
ainsi au coeur du processus visant la
modification de l'âge limite soutenir
les personnes en situation de handicap
et leur apporter les moyens pour
parvenir à l'autonomie et centrale mais
ne doit pas remettre en cause l'un des
piliers de notre politique familiale
cela ne voudrait pas non plus créer de
nouvelles inégalités ni exclure les
départements du pouvoir décisionnaire en
art donne alors dit sans pardon leurs
charges financières
pour toutes ces raisons invoquées en
responsabilité le groupe r&b pays dans
sa majorité votera contre le texte
notre groupe se félicite d'avoir à
nouveau le débat sur l'individualisation
de la vie de l'allocation adulte
handicapé en effet notre groupe avait
porté en 2018 une proposition de loi
visant à ne plus tenir compte des
revenus du conjoint dans le calcul de la
hache cette proposition reprenait la
revendication des associations de
personnes en situation de handicap de
mettre fin à l'injustice des couples qui
perdent le bénéfice de la hache ou
voient leur montant diminuer en cas de
mariage ce que l'on a appelé le prix de
l'amour n'est pas acceptable car elle
rend dépendant économiquement
et personne à l'égard de leur conjoint
cette dépendance économique est d'autant
plus grave que s'agissant des femmes en
situation de handicap
elles sont souvent victimes de violences
conjugales
c'est d'ailleurs le sens du rapport de
la défenseure des droits sur
l'allocation adultes handicapés les
personnes handicapées dit elles doivent
pouvoir être des indépendantes
financièrement il faut donc exclure les
ressources du conjoint pour
l'attribution des allocations accordées
au titre du handicap
permettez moi de faire un bref rappel
historique et de saluer notre collègue
députée communiste marie george buffet
qui dès mars 2018 a déposé cette
proposition de loi
avec le soutien des députés de la
française soumises jusqu'au groupe l'est
républicain
en passant par l'ue dei le modem le ps
et certains députés l air eau m ce
soutien a malheureusement été brisé par
la droite sénatoriale
lorsqu'elle a rejeté notre proposition
de suppression de la prise en compte des
revenus du conjoint dans la base de
calcul de l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés en prétextant la nécessité
d'une refonte globale des aides pour la
compensation du handicap
l'adoption de la proposition de groupe
du groupe liberté territoire en 200
décembre 2019 qui prévoyait la
suppression de la prise en compte des
revenus du conjoint dans le calcul de la
hache étant restées lettre morte au
sénat il aura fallu la mobilisation de
milliers de personnes pour remettre le
métier sur l'ouvragé ainsi la pétition
de madame véronique marie bernadette
tixier déposées sur le site du sénat a
reçu le soutien de plus de cent mille
personnes ce qui est d'autant plus
remarquable que les autres pétitions du
site du sénat plafonne généralement
autour de 200 signatures
c'est le signe d'un soutien large et
profond en faveur de ce sujet je
voudrais saluer le changement de
position de la droite sénatoriale
qui soutient désormais le principe de
l'individualisation de la hache il
s'agit d'une avancée importante pour les
familles et les associations
nous espérons désormais que le consensus
politique autour de l'individualisation
de la hache fera changer d'attitude
le gouvernement l'objectif de
l'individualisation des revenus n'est
pas une question d'économie ou de
cohérence du système d'allocations
familiales mais d'envoyer un message
fort aux personnes en situation de
handicap et de leur montrer que l'on se
soucie de leur condition d'existence et
de leur dignité
le gouvernement refuse et
l'individualisation en invoquant le
nombre trop important de perdants du
changement du mode de calcul la
suppression des revenus du conjoint dans
le calcul de la hat va pourtant
bénéficié à 196 mais le ménage soit 67%
de l'ensemble des couples bénéficiaires
de lâches
dommage que sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le gouvernement ne
suive pas le même raisonnement alors que
le nombre de perdants est estimé autour
de 1 million pourtant des solutions
existent comme celle que propose le
rapporteur philippe couillet avec un
mécanisme transitoire sur dix ans qui
permet aux couples qui le souhaiteraient
de maintenir le système actuel en
prenant compte les revenus du conjoint
notre seul regret est que la majorité
sénatoriale n'est pas proposée en 2018
ce mécanisme transitoire pour éviter de
faire perdre trois ans aux nombreuses
personnes en situation de handicap
c'est désormais au gouvernement de
prendre ses responsabilités et de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent
individualiser la revaloriser le montant
des prestations et suppression des
barrières d'âge de la prade prestation
de compensation du handicap à moyen
terme
nous refusons le transport le transfert
de là
dans la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale car nous estimons que l'âge doit
être intégrée au régime général de
l'assurance maladie au titre du revenu
de remplacement sur le modèle de la
pension d'invalidité
nous voterons pour ce texte
il existe une puissante revendication
d'autonomie financière individuelle dans
nos sociétés cette demande d'un
visualisation des prestations sociales
trouve son inspiration initiale dans les
pays d'europe du nord de culture
scandinave cette revendication ne date
pas d'hier
elle est inspirée par beverage et elle
porte le principe d'universalité
ce n'est pas surprenant que nous
abordions ce débat très intéressant par
l'âge car l'allocation adulte handicapé
est une prestation d'assistance
particulière qui se situe cet éditeur
le rapport va chez à mi chemin entre un
revenu minimum catégorielles et une
prestation compensant l'éloignement de
l'emploi versée comme un substitut de
salaire loin d'être anodine la dea
conjugale isation de l'ach pose la
question de l'individualisation ou de la
fema quasi familiarisation ce sont des
mots tous un peu difficile à prononcer
de notre système de protection sociale
ce débat ne concerne pas que la hache ou
un sens faut il concerne aussi les aides
sociales versées aux jeunes par exemple
et donc nous nous sommes favorables à
cette individualisation de la hache mais
ça ne veut pas dire
l'individualisation de toutes nos
prestations sociales
mes chers collègues à ce jour notre
système de protection sociale repose sur
la contributivité et pas sur
l'individualisation des cotisations et
des prestations c'est sur ces principes
que notre modèle social c'est construire
la libération contre ne nous bien il ne
s'agit pas de nier cette évolution plus
individualiste qui traverse tous les
milieux sociaux et impacte fortement les
expériences familiales de conjugalité de
rupture des individus elles vont pour la
population dans son ensemble et donc
aussi évidemment pour les couples dont
au moins l'une des
personne n'est en situation de handicap
c'est le rôle du législateur d'entendre
et de comprendre cette évolution
à ceci je souhaite rajouter une
situation qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur
celle des femmes en situation de
handicap nous sommes le lendemain de la
journée consacrée aux droits des femmes
saluer le billon qui est présidente de
la délégation et il existe une
aspiration à l'indépendance financière
individuelle propre aux plus jeunes
générations de femmes et c'est légitime
cette indépendance financière est
particulièrement importante car elle
peut permettre à une femme en situation
de handicap d'échapper à son conjoint
violent ou de faire face à des
difficultés d'insertion sociale j'ai été
particulièrement marqué par un chiffre
que j'ai lu dans le rapport de notre
collègue philippe pouillé d'après
l'agencé des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne
34% 34% des femmes handicapées ont subi
des violences physiques ou sexuelles de
la part de leur partenaire contre 19%
c'est déjà considérable des femmes qui
ne sont pas en situation de handicap
c'est une situation un portable un
insupportable des chiffres effrayants
bouleversant qui interroge d'ailleurs
mes chers collègues sur notre condition
masculine
bien sûr nous ne mettrons pas faim ont
des conjugale is an le calcul de l'âge
mais déjà si cela permet à quelques
femmes de prendre leur indépendance
et bien c'est une victoire je le répète
notre groupe est favorable à cette ppl
mais nous souhaitons interpeller cette
assemblée sur d'éventuels risques
d'effets en cascade et les prévenir par
avance nous voulons aussi réaffirmer
notre attachement à la solidarité
familiale et donc mettre en garde contre
les risques qu'engendre est une des
familiarisation comme j'étais tout à
l'heure généralisée de notre système de
protection sociale ça nous ne le voulons
pas enfin j'aborderai la question ça a
été peu abordée mais de la dépense
publique et de la dette publique
je souhaite l'abordé avec gravité avec
une grande clarté l'argent public dans
notre pays n'est pas un robinet que nous
pouvons ouvrir sans compter sans en
mesurer clairement l'impact à long terme
selon une étude de la drees la mesure
votée en l'état par l'assemblée
nationale aurait eu ou aurait un coût de
20 milliards d'euros pour non dépense
publique
je trouve d'ailleurs
problématique que nos collègues députés
voter un texte sans mesurer précisément
l'impact financier
ça vaut d'ailleurs pour beaucoup de
paypal ou de projet de loi le
gouvernement a annoncé la semaine
dernière que le déficit public devrait
être de 10% du pib en 2021 ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
de dette que nous allons transmettre aux
générations futures
et si nous voulons éviter une génération
sacrifiée
nous devons prendre en compte cette
question de la dette publique et donc
veiller à haut niveau de dépenses je
tiens donc d'autant plus à saluer la
décision de modification de l'article 3
qui ont cadre le principe de plafond de
cumul de la prestation avec les
ressources personnelles du bénéficiaire
et salué l'esprit de responsabilité de
notre rapporteur qui a réussi à
circonscrire cette dé conjugale isation
de de lâches
le groupe union centriste se félicite
enfin du report de 60 ans à 65 ans de la
barrière d'âge au delà de laquelle il
n'est sauf exception plus possible de
solliciter la pch
cette proposition de loi qui arrive
quelques mois après la création de la
5ème branche nous aura permis d'échanger
sur la situation de nos compatriotes les
plus fragiles qui vivent une situation
de handicap
je pense que nous devons saisir à
l'avenir l'opportunité ouverte par cette
nouvelle branche pour mener un véritable
travail de fond d'évaluation de nos
politiques à destination des publics
porteurs de handicap en abordant aussi
courageusement la question de leur
financement
nos collectivités notamment les
départements font un travail formidable
sur ces questions cependant ils ne
disposent pas toujours des moyens
financiers d liberté d'action nécessaire
pour agir
donnons-nous rapidement l'ambition de
travailler avec eux à la mise en place
d'un nouveau cadre pour nos politiques
en faveur du handicap
tout ceci étant exprime au nom du groupe
uc notre groupe votera en faveur de
cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie
la discussion générale est un klose deux
ans passés à l'examen du texte de la
commission
l'article 1er est supprimé à l'article 2
une demande de parole d'abord de bernard
jomier merci madame la présidente je
souhaitais au moment où on entre on dans
l'étude des articles portant pardon sur
la question l'ade et conjugale isation
dire quelques mots
madame la ministre la situation n'est
pas forcément la plus confortable pour
vous puisque vous venez discuter avec
nous d'une ppl qui a été adopté contre
l'avis du gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
nous nous souvenons des conditions de
cette adoption quelques jours après une
polémique sur le vote du prolongement du
projet lié à la perte d'un enfant la
majorité ne voulant pas passer pour un
sensible aux questions d'humanité
aujourd'hui vous êtes favorable au
maintien de la conjugalité ation de la
hache
ce n'est pas l'avis des associations et
des collectifs de personnes en situation
de handicap
ce n'est pas l'avis de vos grands
partenaires que sont la cns a ou le
comité national consultatif des
personnes handicapées vous avancé l'idée
que 44 mille bénéficiaires seraient
perdants nous voudrions savoir comment
d'abord ce chiffre a été calculé
parce que malgré un effort considérable
pour centraliser les données liées au
handicap
beaucoup restent aujourd'hui éclatée à
l'image par exemple du chiffre du
chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap dont nous ne disposons que trop
peu souvent
et vous le savez le rapporteur vous l'a
dit un mécanisme de droits d'option
suffirait à enrayer les effets négatifs
de cette loi et contrairement à ce que
j'ai entendu ce ne serait ni complexe ni
discriminatoire en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale vous aviez a
avancé des arguments d'ordre idéologique
au sens tout à fait positif et humain
l'importance de la solidarité nationale
et l'investissement sur l'emploi plutôt
que l'aide sociale
entre temps une année a passé une crise
sanitaire un changement de gouvernement
et aujourd'hui nous entendons également
des arguments de nature budget
terre certes les personnes en situation
de handicap bénéficient d'abattements
mais vous le savez tout est plus cher
quand on est en situation de handicap
les études les déplacements la vie
quotidienne l'équipement informatique
l'immobilier l'émancipation par le droit
commun ne se limite pas au travail à la
scolarisation
c'est aussi de pouvoir vivre décemment
alors madame la ministre lors de la
conférence nationale du handicap en
février 2020 le président la république
a déclaré ce que nous poursuivons n'est
pas de ne pas s'occuper au moins
s'occuper de ces françaises et des
français au contraire
en voici l'occasion jour merci merci
monsieur daniel sans merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
présidente de commission mais selon à
porter mes chers collègues qui a
quelques mots sur l'article 2 et 3 qui
souhaite affirmer la solidarité
nationale par rapport la solidarité
familiale en supprimant donc la prise en
compte des revenus du conjoint pour
obtenir lâche est aux planches voudrais
rappeler que ces tâches a été créé en
1975 dans le gouvernement de jacques
chirac et elle bénéficie un million de
personnes et pour un coût de 11 millions
donc la prise en compte des revenus du
conjoint peut entraîner effectivement
comme ça a été dit une diminution
importante des revenus jusqu'à même une
suppression c'est la solidarité
familiale avec une possible relation
parfois de dépendance financière
effectivement vis-à-vis du conjoint une
sorte de violence c'est vrai même si la
violence n'est pas toujours financière
et donc dans cette loi donc les les
études réalisées montrent aussi des
modifications qui entraîne
souvent des perdantes comme ça a été dit
par mon âme le miss 44000 couple mêmes
125000 concernant la suppression du
plafond de l'enfant à charge donc ces
ménages perdent bien sûr et c'est un
préjudice alors je voudrais rendre
hommage à la commission et aux
rapporteurs qui finalement à
rééquilibrer ce texte alors en retirant
les revenus du conjoint de les revenus
du couple
alors ça va coûter certains 10570
d'autres d'autres 2 milliards mais c'est
vrai que je rejoins olivier neau
on ne pourra pas effectivement
individualisé l'ensemble des prestations
parce que il ya aussi quand même des
dettes à à contrôler est aussi proposé
une transition pour les bénéficiaires de
la hache qui pourrait perdre des revenus
du fait d'une des consuls juqu'à
lisation des prestations et surtout bien
sûr à l'article 3 qu'on verra tout à
l'heure la commission ont rétabli le
cumul des prestations à h avec les
revenus des ressources personnelles du 5
août et 20 milliards
donc je me rends hommage donc aux
rapporteurs philippe bouyer qui merci
produire ce texte équilibré
merci je vais mettre revoir l'article 2
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté à l'article 3 une demande
de parole de monsieur mickaël vallet la
ministre je souhaite m'exprimer sur
l'amendement que j'ai déposée pour
compléter l'article 3 de cette
proposition de loi
c'est un amendement qui vise à combler
une faille de la proposition de loi dans
soutient par ailleurs le principe
général
si cette proposition de loi est adoptée
elle mettra fin à l'inégalité qui voyait
le bénéficiaire dépendant des revenus de
l'époux pour le calcul de la hache
pendant le mariage et c'est bien ainsi
mais on ne peut pas raisonner mes chers
collègues simplement en considérant
l'avant le pendant
après mariage il existe un autre temps
qui est celui de la transition entre les
séparation de fait des poux toujours
marié endroit mais qui sont engagés dans
une procédure de divorce et l'obtention
d'un jugement de divorce définitif
concrètement de quoi s'agit-il un couple
marié décide de se séparer l'un des deux
est bénéficiaire de la hache et à moins
de revenus que l'autre il s'agit
quasiment toujours de l'épouser
évidemment chacun prend un logement
distincts et il passe devant le juge
pour obtenir une ordonnance de
non-conciliation situation aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus fréquente parmi les
mesures à la disposition du juge en cas
de disparité de revenus entre époux
figure la pension de secours
c'est un filet de sécurité indispensable
et très utilisé elle permet au conjoint
percevant moins de revenus de ne pas
être dépendant durant cette période des
revenus de son époux pour traverser
cette période transitoire jusqu'au
divorce dans les moins mauvaises
conditions possibles mais le juge se
trouve privé de la possibilité pratique
d'accorder à les pouces bénéficiaires de
la hache la pension de secours à
laquelle elle a droit
car cette pension entre dans le calcul
de la hache
ce qui est assez ubuesque du point de
vue de l'usager
les pousses bénéficiaires de l'aj qui
divorce doit donc quasiment choisir
entre demander une pension de secours et
continuent à conserver son h alors que
cette prestation d'une part et cette
allocation d'autre part ne remplissent
pas les mêmes fonctions et en suisse ont
toutes les deux indispensables
l'adoption de l'amendement permettrait
la proposition de loi de produire ses
pleins effets pendant toute la durée du
mariage
cela permettrait à une bénéficiaire de
l'aj de ne pas dépendre de son époux
dans la période allant de l' ordonnance
de non-conciliation au divorce définitif
or cette période et des injustices qui
peuvent en découler peuvent durer
pendant des années nous pouvons mettre
fin à cette inégalité l'amendement le
permet je vous remercie par avance
c'est le cheval est ce que je considère
que votre amendement est défendu très
bien
quel est l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement alors c'est un amendement
retire donc de l'assiette des revenus
plus en compte pour calculer lâche les
créances nées des liens du mariage pour
sue alimentaire participation charge du
foyer ou encore prestation compensatoire
après un divorce
l'argument pu surprendre alors qu'on
présente l âge conjugue elysées comme un
obstacle à la vie en couple
voilà qu'elle apparaît aussi comme un
empêchant le divorce on comprend
cependant l'intention de l'auteur qui
vise à retirer la lâche au caractère
subsidiaire à certaines ressources dont
celles qui peuvent naître en cas de
divorce du manquement aux obligations
qu'un conjoint envers l'autre l'idée que
l'âge de watney location compensant un
état et donc ne pas donner lieu à
interférence avec la perception d'autres
ressources
il voit toutefois distinguer les
logiques de ces différentes créances la
pension versée en application du devoir
de secours vise le conjoint qui se
retrouvaient dans le besoin la logique
étant proche de celle de la hague
il n'est pas absurde que les deux
prestations ne soit pas cumulables la
prestation compensatoire biz elle a
compensé la disparité que la rupture du
mariage crée dans les conditions de vies
respectives
sauf qu'elle n'est en principe pas prise
en compte dans le calcul de la hache
puisqu'elle n'est pas imposable
dès lors qu'elle est versée dans les
douze mois suivant le prononcé du
divorce et peut donc en principe est de
cumuler avec la hache ce qui satisferait
l'amendement de ce fait c'est un avis
défavorable et l'avis du gouvernement
sur cet amendement
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente vous demandez
que les pensions que pourrait recevoir
un bénéficiaire de la hache en
application du code civil soient exclus
des ressources prises en compte pour le
calcul de cette allocation ce qui aurait
pour objet de faciliter les séparations
tout d'abord je tiens à signaler que ces
pensions peuvent être de nature
différente
elle ne concerne pas seulement les
prestations alimentaires des pensions
alimentaires ou les prestations
compensatoires à contre ex conjoint mais
aussi les versements effectués par les
parents pour venir en aide à leurs
enfants
je pense que je suis vous le savez
attentive à protéger les droits des
personnes en situation d'handicap en
particulier des femmes victimes de
violences mais la solution que vous
proposez ne me semble pas traiter le
problème bien réel
non perception des pensions alimentaires
ou des prestations compensatoires des
dispositifs existent ils permettent à la
caf de procéder au recouvrement des
sommes dues dès leurs premiers impayés
ou encore de verser une allocation de
substitution à la pension alimentaire de
cinq ans de 115 euros
il nous faut maintenant nous assurer que
ces femmes fassent valoir pleinement
leurs droits
c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé les travaux
portés par des acteurs de terrain afin
de pouvoir identifier les leviers rain
man opérant pour un accompagnement
adapté le plus protecteur de l'emprise
dont elle peut faire l'objet
je suis donc défavorable à votre
amendement je vais donc mettre aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée je
me vois l'article 3 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
me vois l'article 3 bis qui pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
après l'article 3 bis un amendement de
madame menu la présidente afin d'éviter
le versement sur un compte joint qui
pourrait priver la personne en situation
de handicap de l'autonomie de gestion de
ses ressources ce qui constitue un
facteur de dépendance supplémentaire
il est proposé de rendre obligatoire le
versement de la hache sur un compte
bancaire individuel au nom de la
locataire
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
sur cet amendement
alors donc cet amendement oblige la cnaf
a versé lâche sur le combo cas
individuels du bénéficiaire
il s'agit d'éviter qu'une éventuelle
dépendance d'un allocataire de la chasse
aux projets ne soient accrues par
l'impossibilité de disposer à sa guise
de son allocation
on comprend les motivations donc de
l'auteur de cet amendement
toutefois la cnaf peut déjà versé la
prestation sur un compte individuel
puisque elle verse l'allocation sur le
compte que le bénéficiaire aura indiquée
il n'est sans doute pas opportun d'en
faire une obligation satin à leucate a
d'ailleurs préfère sans doute que la
choix d'accessoires conjoint et nous
avons consulté les et gestion du monde
du handicap qui sont mitigés sur cette
obligation donc au pour toutes ces
raisons c'est un avis défavorable
quel est l'avis du gouvernement merci à
la précédente votre amendement vise à
conditionner donc le versement de la
hache à l'ouverture d'un compte bancaire
individuel au nom du bénéficiaire
l'objectif est de garantir l'autonomie
financière de la locataire mais je tiens
à vous rappeler qu'il est d'ores et déjà
possible pour un allocataire de demander
à ce que sa prestation soit versé sur
son compte bancaire personnel et que
cette demande peut être faite à tout
moment cet amendement me semble donc
inutile d'autant qu'il pourrait aller à
l'encontre de la décision prise d'un
commun accord par la personne
bénéficiaire de la hache et son conjoint
de partager le compte bancaire
je suis bien sûr comme vous très attaché
à la libre disposition des allocataires
de leur prestation est très sensible à
la situation des femmes en situation de
handicap victimes de violences
conjugales je pense toutefois que la
solution réside davantage dans le
renforcement de la compagnon
l'accompagnement de ces femmes pour leur
permettre de mener à bien leurs
démarches en matière de comptes
bancaires comme de logement coût d'accès
au droit
en ce sens je suis défavorable à votre
amendement pas d'explications de vote je
vais donc mettre on voit cet amendement
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
elle n'est pas adoptée après l'article 3
bis 1 un amendement toujours de madame
meunier c'est donc il défendu oui merci
mme la présidente sans illusion
puisqu'il s'agit d'un rapport et je
connais le sort des rapports ici au
sénat
cet amendement prévoit donc un rapport
pour évaluer l'impact réel de
l'application de cette proposition de
loi et connaître dans le détail la
source et le calcul des chiffres qui
sont annoncés par madame la ministre a
dit monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission
l'auteur de cet amendement a déjà évoqué
ce sujet donc l'avis est défavorable
mais en tous les cas on il est certain
qu'il ya une urgence armes et assoit sur
le sur la table
les évaluations les calculs on revient
aujourd'hui qu'on manque d'outils
statistiques précis soit que c'est un
message que nous devons porter ici dans
cet hémicycle mai auprès du gouvernement
à la fois pour pouvoir avoir des
éléments tangibles d'analysé et surtout
que nous ayons la capacité réelle
d'aborder la loi
las future loi sur l'autonomie avec des
éléments de travail disponible et
efficace voilà donc je crois que c'est
un message que nous devons donner et
donc au delà du rapport proposent
justement que la commission se saisisse
de ces enjeux là le plus rapidement
possible mais sur un porteur défavorable
oui madame la ministre cet amendement
souligne une nouvelle fois que nos
discussions bien sûr ne s'appuie pas sur
une évaluation partagée par l'ensemble
des acteurs prenant en compte les
conséquences réelles pour nos
concitoyens de la réforme que vous
proposez c'est un vrai enjeu en effet
deux sociétés de travailler à
l'amélioration de ces dispositifs et de
cette connaissance et nous devons y
travailler mais en l'occurrence je suis
défavorable à cet amendement
madame cohen pour une explication de
vote oui en jeu j'entends bien la
position du gouvernement est d'ailleurs
dans votre propos introductif madame la
ministre vous avez dit que vous alliez
travailler justement à essayer de bien
évaluer les différents dispositifs pour
aller dans un sens positif pour les
personnes en situation de handicap mais
j'ai quand même un doute madame la
ministre pour quoi j'ai un doute
et bien parce que vous nous aviez déjà
dit la même chose en 2018
en parlant en tout cas d'une étude
d'impact quand il s'est agi de refuser
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
députée marie-george buffet alors ce
n'était pas vous en tant que tel mais
c'était votre gouvernement la même chose
en 2018 quand au sénat nous avons fait
notre proposition de loi nous allons
nous a opposé au niveau gouvernemental
mental le besoin de faire une étude
d'impact et la même chose en commission
alors 2018 2021
c'est pas un scoop mais ça fait trois
ans alors trois ans pour faire une étude
d'impact il me semble que vous avez eu
le temps donc je pense quand même que à
un moment donné les études d'impact sont
effectivement des éléments importants
mais il ya l'initiative parlementaire
et là je trouve que si vous voulez il ya
des avancées considérables qui ont été
faites une amélioration au niveau de la
proposition de loi initiale qui
justement prend compte éventuellement
les perdants comme c'était notre souci à
toutes et à tous quels que soient les
bancs sur les bancs de cette assemblée
et je trouve dommageable finalement de
demander encore du temps pour des études
d'impact parce que du coup et bien ce
sont les personnes qui sont en situation
de handicap et nous avons été une
délégation de parlementaires deux
sénatrices et sénateurs notamment de
notre groupe et pas que de notre groupe
à nous rendre devant le sénat tout à
l'heure parce que il y avait des
manifestants qui sont très soucieux
justement de cette individualisation de
de cette allocation et nous aimerions
quand même que les choses aillent
nettement plus vite et que vous
souteniez les propositions qui sont
faites ici même mais ça varie
oui merci madame la présidente
effectivement c'est l'occasion à l'âme
la ministre de voir un peu l'ambiguïté
du dispositif et la situation dans
laquelle vous vous êtes mise en vous
opposant à cette loi rapplique ce n'est
pas revenu universel puisque le
président de la république l'a exclu des
intervenu c'est pas dans la 5ème branche
donc on pose des questions par rapport
aux financements tout à fait logique
est ce que sera l'élève de l'état du
budget de l'état est-ce que ça relèvera
à travers une cinquième branche qui est
pour prison un qui est là pour prendre
en charge justement c'est peu ses
problèmes de dépendance de perte
d'autonomie ou bien deux
de handicap et donc du budget de la
sécurité sociale
parce que là la proposition de loi qui
est faite elle est financée actuellement
sur l'état du tabac ça va pas durer
aussi longtemps que les contributions
on ne sait bien mais faudra bien
répondre à toutes ces questions
et là vous n'avez pas encore répondu en
ce qui concerne l'impact j'ai eu une
discussion très intéressante hier avec
votre assistante parlementaire et qui me
disait que l'impact serait de en ce qui
concerne la transition pour les quarante
quatre mille personnes 2,2 milliards
d'euros c'est un chiffre qu'on a qu'on
n'a pas évalué plus que ça je vois que
le rapporteur opine de la tête donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'imprécisions et c'est quand même
particulièrement difficile d'avancer
dans une prestation favorable au monde
du handicap sans en mesurer exactement
l'impact et sans savoir sur quel budget
alors je me posais la question en tant
que président de la mission d'évaluation
des comptes sociaux si on ne rêvait pas
si je devais pas faire une mission par
exemple mais aujourd'hui je ne sais même
pas si c'est sur les comptes sociaux
donc on ne peut même pas proposé une
mission d'évaluation de la prestation
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire
donc faudra bien arriver a précisé
madame la ministre qu'elle est est
exactement la place de cette allocation
adulte handicapé par rapport aux autres
prestations sociales ou familiales
dépendants ou de l'état ou du budget de
la crise et aux rites et sociale ou du
budget des départements parce que là
aussi il ya un impact significatif ni
seront vous souhaitez répondre monsieur
savary nous avons eu un début de
discussion identique lors de l'audition
en effet je vous réaffirme haut et fort
que l'allocation adulte handicapé est un
minima un i mean asocial qu'il est dans
le budget de l'état actuellement et que
donc en tant que tel il se doit d'être
fiscalisés conjugale is est familier
familiariser
pardon familialiser comme au toute
allocation en ce qui concerne les
couples aujourd'hui pourquoi il a été
évacué du et rurale parce qu'il y avait
aussi une dimension de contrepartie de
reprise d'activité et c'est bien ce que
le président a dit c'est qu'il n'était
pas question pour les personnes en
situation de handicap d'avoir cette
contrepartie de reprise d'activité c'est
pour cela qu'il ya une parole forte lors
de la conférence nationale du handicap
du président de la république et la pch
en revanche elle est bien une prestation
individuelle sans condition de
ressources qui traite la situation de
handicap
donc j'espère que cela ait clarifié pour
parvenir à madame la sénatrice
c'est bien pour cela que l'état remis 25
millions dans les systèmes informatiques
des maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées pour que nous
ayons enfin je dis bien enfin car la loi
de 2005 n'est pas allé au fond
puisqu'elle à préserver l'autonomie des
départements de choisir leurs systèmes
informatiques et que nous avons perdu 15
ans quand le gouvernement est arrivée
nous avons remis 25 millions pour aider
justement les départements à avoir un
système d'informatique commun pour voir
partager les besoins et les moyens mis à
disposition des personnes en situation
d'handicap donc nous allons vers du
mieux nous irons vers du mieux pour
évaluer en effet tout ce que j'ai
octroyé et tous les besoins des
personnes en situation de handicap bien
merci je mets trouve à cet amendement
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable
pardon quelqu'un d'autre mais son
rapporteur
oui mais ne le présente seulement une
position pour nous tout cas l'ex mari
dans les évaluations extrêmement
complexe de ses thèses loi s'il a une
qui est à peu près la plus facile c'est
la page sur les perdants ce qu'on les
connaît on connaît les montants qu'ils
perçoivent ils évaluent à soues québec
est donné et donc notre dans nos travaux
l'impact et 240 millions d'euros
donc c'est très loin des 2 milliard et
dont je faisais le préciser parce que
lorsqu'on ne veut pas d'un sujet on
dispute ou quand on veut montrer que son
chien
voilà on cherchait un malade dont bull
doit donc je vois la horde et sur 140
millions merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement car c'est un double avis
défavorable qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adoptée à l'article
4 un amendement numéro 6 de monsieur
covelli
présidente madame amis disent mes chers
collègues l'article iv dans son écriture
actuelle est porteur d'une grande
complexité
d'abord une complexité logistique tout
d'abord en modifiant l'article l 245
tirer 1 du code de l'action sociale et
des familles en y ajoutant une limite à
la limite fixée par décret de façon
explicite dans le texte
une complexité administrative ensuite
pour les départements ensuite cette
complexité à d'ailleurs été soulignée
par le rapporteur lui même dans son
rapport la direction générale de la
cohésion sociale ayant admis que la
gestion d'un tel droit d'option
représenterait une lourdeur
administrative pour les services chargés
de l'instruction des prestations
notamment sur les territoires n'ayant
pas mis en place la maison
départementale de l'autonomie assurant
la gestion conjointe de l'apa et de la
pch
cette concurrence entre les deux
prestations seraient également source de
complexité pour les usagers et leurs
aidants et enfin une complexité
financière pour les départements encore
par le coup de l'ajout de cette limite à
65 ans qui ne serait pas partiellement
compensé par l'état et qui coûterait
près de 20 millions d'euros
toutes ces complexités existait pourtant
aucune concertation avec les
départements n'ont eu lieu alors même
qu'ils sont les premiers ont ils sont
les au premier plan de cette mesure
notre amendement donc propose d'y
pallier en assurant plutôt que l'âge
limite puisse être réévalué de manière
régulière plutôt qu'une limite s'est
fixé dans la loi
si tous les sens en cinq ans l'âge déjà
défini n'a pas besoin d'être modifié
alors celui ci resterait le même il n'y
aurait donc aucune nouvelle complexité
pour les départements sans leur accord
ce qui est ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
la rédaction actuelle des articles
cette réévaluation serait
lisez suite à une concertation avec les
départements essentiellement alors que
les départements sont au coeur des
politiques de l'autonomie il est
regrettable de prendre des décisions qui
aura un impact considérable sont les
inclura la réflexion c'est pour assurer
qu'à l'avenir l'âge limite puisse
évoluer afin de répondre au mieux aux
situations des personnes handicapées et
permettre au département au coeur de
cette concertation que nous portons cet
amendement merci quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
mais j'aurais profité de cet instant
pour répondre à notre collègue sénateur
dans ses plaidoiries
je dirais très très anti cet article
d'une façon générale tous appelé votre
globale sur le texte de loi d'abord pour
vous dire que lorsque nous ce que nous
avons travaillé sur le sujet porteuse
nous avons constaté les départements
nous avons demandé la nuit ils nous ont
d'ailleurs évoqué que c'était une
vieille revendication ou jeu les sablons
vous apporter cette information dans
lequel les départements et travailler là
dessus
nous avons ensuite fait chiffrer avec
l'adresse l'estimation sur le sujet la
destination qui nous a été donnée a été
confronté par les départements précisant
que le coup pouvait être glissés entre 5
et 20 millions d'euros entre les
avantages des inconvénients faire plus
de pch mais moins d'appât donc je
voudrais juste reprise et des chiffres
constatée garante les départements et
puis ensuite votre argument concernant
une volonté de simplification je crois
plutôt une complexité
parce que le vrai sujet concernant la
pch c'est la notion de parcours de vie
l'étape suivante c'est quoi landes juste
une étape l'étape suivante c'est quoi
c'est justement faire en sorte qu'on
prenne en considération les besoins de
la personne quel que soit son âge et
donc on est cet arbitrage sur
l'accompagnement donc vous propose
aujourd'hui un système intermédiaire qui
viendrait à mon avis plutôt rencontrer
encore plus de complexité à la situation
et je crois que là vous avez en tout cas
raison se trouve c'est l'urgence d'avoir
un texte concernant la loi sur
l'autonomie pour pu constater que les
départements pour la prise en charge des
personnes ce qui pour moi un point
essentiel voilà donc un avis défavorable
et quelques précisions à homer de vos
propos madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur genre vous même je
vous remercie de portée par un vote
votre amendement la voie des
départements vous le savez je porte dans
le champ des politiques du handicap dans
lequel l'état est en coresponsabilité
avec les départements une démarche
systématique de concertation d'entendre
sur les objectifs comme en témoignent
des corps de méthodes inédit entre
l'état et l'association des départements
de france signé avec le président
bûcheron qui a permis d'améliorer de
façon significative le fonctionnement et
la feuille de route des mdph
je regrette donc également cette absence
de concertation avec les départements
alors que la mesure adoptée représente à
la fois une charge financière nouvelle
une source importante de complexité pour
les usagers leurs familles et les
services chargés de les orienter dans
les démarches
ce nouveau dispositif instaurant un
droit d'option entre pch et appâts pour
les publics de 60 à 65 ans aurait est
vendu à des ventes
évidemment dû être beaucoup plus
concertée dans cet état d'esprit je
remets je m'en remet sur cet amendement
à la sagesse de la chambre haute pour
veiller aux intérêts des collectivités
je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement mais pas avant d'avoir passé
la parole à rené paul savary
oui merci moi je crois que on est tous
défenseurs nos territoires défenseur des
départements pas de plus les uns que les
autres et ce qui nous intéresse il
replaçait la personne handicapée au sein
du dispositif quel que soit celui qui
qui paye les prestations c'est un sujet
très intéressant mais je pense que même
de passer l'âge à 60 65 ans quand vous
êtes d'une paix ces ajouts vous allez
vers la dépendance par le biais de la
page je crois que une barrière d'âge
c'est toujours une barrière et la
personne est identique
la veille de son anniversaire à la le
même handicap et puis le lendemain
bassel une dépendance elle veut sortir
non c'est pas concevable faut vraiment
trouver madame la ministre
une meilleure articulation ce type de
prestation fo se simplifier la vie et
simplifier la vie surtout de ces
personnes en situation de dépendance
avec les moyens numériques maintenant il
ya véritablement c'est les mêmes
demandent quel est le foyer ou
habilité voir venu vous aussi vous ça
etc il ya un panel administratif et en
france on sait faire quand même un bon
il ya un panel administratif est
extraordinaire c'est le même c'est le
même et on doit pouvoir passer d'une
prestation à l'autre sans avoir de
barrières c'est l'occasion justement de
travailler sur un rapprochement non pas
une concurrence entre les deux
instructions de prestations mais un
rapprochement de cette instruction de
façon à rendre encore un meilleur
service à en savoir les concertations
sont au courant de ces les départements
pardon sont au courant de cette cette
prestation peut pas dire qu'il ya pas eu
concertation mais si vous les interrogez
individuellement il y en a qui vont être
favorable mais on a qui vont dire non je
suis pas tout à fait mûr etc
mais ce qui est important qu'ils aient
une maison au poids de l'autonomie c'est
d'aller vers un rapprochement de ce type
de prestation en ce qui concerne
l'instruction
on pourrait penser que il ya un choix
même s'il ya double instruction c sont
les mêmes éléments
après on arrivera avec les moyens
digital savoir quelle est la réponse
financière à l'une ou l'autre des
prestations donc je crois que la formule
n'est pas encore idéal mais elle doit
contribuer à la réflexion pour aller
vers une amélioration du dispositif
surtout qu'est mesuré sans thème la
présidente madame ministre président
richard clegg dont l'article iv se
propose de relever la barrière d'âge
pour solliciter la pch bon cela
améliorera la complète la couverture des
besoins des personnes de plus de 60 ans
éligibles à lapins pour la porter à 65
ans mais je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire si ça varie pour essayer
d'avoir un rapprochement entre les deux
la pch donc est une aide versée par
département comme la pac qui permet de
rembourser les dépenses liées à la perte
d'autonomie il ya cinq aides et humaines
techniques logement transport est
spécifique
je rappelle qu'après 60 ans la pch ne
pouvait pas être réclamés sauf si le
handicap existait avant 60 ans et dans
ce cas la demande pouvait être porté
jusqu'à 65 75 ans c'est vrai que c'est
complexe donc la loi du 11 février 2005
prévoyait déjà c'est vrai dans un délai
de 50 de faire évoluer la barrière d'âge
donc la pch
il faut dire elle est quand même a
priori plus avantageuse que la pas la
passer à 65 ans moi j'y suis favorable
ils font un rapprochement sûrement avec
l'apa mais cela un coûteux et donc il
faut bien sûr une compensation de l'état
vis-à-vis des départements et un accord
et effectivement des conseils
départementaux comme l'a rappelé madame
le ministre
merci messieurs iacovelli oui madame la
présidente monsieur rapporteur juste je
reprenais les éléments de votre rapport
cette complexité à d'ailleurs été
soulignée par le rapporteur dans son
rapport s'effacer quand même vous qui
l'avez indiqué et d'ailleurs je m'appuie
vraiment sur votre rapport
après monsieur savary vous avez aussi
raison je suis complètement d'accord et
vous sur la complexité du dispositif est
donc d'où l'importance d'avoir une vraie
concertation un vrai travail avec les
départements l'ensemble du département
les associations concernées pour qu'on
puisse effectivement aboutir à un
système plus simple pour les usagers
moins contraignants et surtout concertée
et qui ne soit pas non plus une source
de complexité administrative pour les
départements quand on sait dans la
situation dans laquelle ils sont
actuellement
donc je maintiens mon amendement et
j'invite à 9,6 je vais donc mettre voit
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et un avis
de sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
je vais aux voix l'article 4 qui est
pour et qui est contre il est adopté
après l'article 4 un amendement monsieur
savin merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre sur le rapporteur cet
amendement vise à exclure les primes
versées par l'état aux sportifs de
l'équipe de france médaillée aux jeux
paralympiques du calcul du plafond de
ressources d'attribution des différentes
prestations sociales qui sont versées
aux personnes en situation de handicap
l'allocation adulte handicapé prestation
de compensation handicap est forfait
journalier en cas de séjour dans un
établissement médico social
par ailleurs c'est à cet amendement
vient également exclure les aides
ponctuelles attribué par l' agence
nationale du sport du calcul du plafond
de ressources d'attribution de la hache
dans le cadre du soutien aux sportifs de
haut niveau
l' agence nationale verse donc des aides
ciblées à certains sportifs pour
contribuer à leur préparation sportive
et soutenir leurs performances notamment
dans la perspective des jeux
paralympiques
or certains bénéficiaires de ces aides
se voit privé de l'âge
dès lors qu'ils bénéficient de ces aides
ponctuelles merci quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement 3
maintenant la président de la commission
a émis un avis favorable à cet
amendement retire les primes de
performances des sportifs paralympiques
de l'assiette de ressources prises en
compte pour le calcul de la hache
ces dispositions se contente de codifier
plus précisément l'intention du
dictateur figurant à l'article 90 du
collectif budgétaire pour 2012 qui
disposait que ces primes sont exclus des
revenus pris en compte pour
l'attribution des prestations en espèces
ou en nature versés aux personnes du
fait de leur handicap
l'allemande mans ajoute toutefois un
élément nouveau en disposant que les
aides ponctuelles de l' agence nationale
du sport sont elles aussi exclu de la
base de calcul de la hache l'article 40
empêchant de faire de même pour les
autres dispositifs que sont le pc ou les
ventes et joaillier m'ont tous les cas
concernant la hache cet amendement donc
correspond à notre motivation c'est un
avis favorable
merci
quel est l'avis du gouvernement le
gouvernement salue les compétences et le
rôle modèle en effet des athlètes
paralympiques qui donne à voir les
situations de handicap sous un angle
différent pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
il n'est cependant pas envisagé de
permettre l'exclusion de ces primes et
aides ponctuelles des ressources prises
en compte pour le calcul de la hache ou
d autres prestations
c'est une question d'équité de
traitement entre les bénéficiaires dans
la prise en compte de leurs revenus
qu'ils soient issus de leurs exploits
sportifs ou d'autres activités
je suis donc défavorable à cet
amendement bien n'est-il des estimations
de vote dans cette amo non monsieur
savard vous souhaitez reprendre la
parole dont j'ai juste pour épier
expliqué madame la ministre
aujourd'hui des ressources de cette
demande des personnes handicapées au
niveau lâchez pas des ressources qui
sont mirobolantes et c'est vrai que
l'effort qui est fait aujourd'hui par
l'agencé voulue par le gouvernement de
soutenir les athlètes qui préparent les
jeux paralympiques
il est quand même regrettable que le
fait de pouvoir soutenir comme c'est le
cas tous les athlètes valides les
athlètes paralympiques et qu'ils soient
pénalisés c'est chaque fois que ça va
dépasser le montant à hdc les ressources
qui vont venir en déduction et je trouve
que c'est vraiment regrettable en
direction d'un public qui déjà connaît
beaucoup de difficultés
le fait de l'accompagner et or jules
pénalisant dont je sais c'est vraiment
dommage que la position du gouvernement
je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 3 qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission est
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
nous allons maintenant mettre non c'est
bon article 5 est supprimé je mets aux
voix l'article 6 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition doit y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote madame lubin
madame lubin madame apourceau poly même
lubin les i melhem la ministre le
handicap ne se partage pas aujourd'hui
pour la plupart fin pour les personnes
concernées c'est la triple peine
suis handicapé je ne peux pas travailler
et je ne peux pas percevoir une
allocation à laquelle je pourrais
éventuellement avoir droit
parce que la personne avec qui je vis
perçoit un revenu qui m'interdit
finalement de percevoir cette allocation
est en revenus qui n'est pas somme toute
mirobolants autant nous comprenons et
nous sommes même tout à fait d'accord
pour qu'un certain nombre de prestations
des pins de du revenus soit même des
allocations différentielles autant celle
ci il faut vraiment qu'on évolue dessus
parce qu'elle est liée à un état de fait
je vais attendre que monsieur patriat
est terminée si j'ai le temps voilà
autant elles dépendent d'un état de fait
à laquelle la personne ne peut
strictement rien
tout cela madame la ministre nous nous
vous l'apprenions pas parce que vous
êtes pleinement investi dans votre
mission vous le savez pertinemment
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets dont la situation financière des
départements c'est une évidence mais
quand on parle de la situation
financière des départements on parle des
allocations individuelles en général où
l'état ne respecte pas sa parole et ce
depuis que ça a été mis en place et
quels que soient les gouvernements
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
revoir dans son intégralité pour toutes
les allocations individuelles et sur ce
sujet là toutes les personnes
handicapées qui se sont mobilisés sont
aujourd'hui en attente
elles ont un espoir qui est considérable
entre le vote qui a déjà eu lieu à
l'assemblée et le vote qui interviendra
maintenant
donc moi je suis persuadé nous sommes
persuadés que vous n'avez pas peur
parfaitement consciente et vraiment il
faudrait que nous ayons avancé avant la
fin de ce quinquennat mais pas avancé
sur des rapports sur des sait trouver
les financements parce que je suis à peu
près persuadé que même au gouvernement
tout le monde le comprend
le bien fondé de ses propositions de loi
la parole est maintenant pour s'opposer
oui merci madame la présidente
j'avais l'occasion de le rappeler tout à
l'heure et ma collègue laurence cohen a
dit la même chose mars 2018
marie george buffet députés communistes
déposent une proposition de loi
transpartisane voté à l'assemblée
nationale le 24 octobre 2018
nous déposons la même proposition de loi
le groupe sérieux communistes et
républicains écologistes nous la
dénonçons dans cet hémicycle
elle n'est pas voté je n'ose imaginer et
nous n'osons imaginer que vous n'avez
pas voté cette proposition de loi mes
chers collègues parce que nous sommes
communiste et parce que quand les
communistes déposent une proposition de
loi dans cet hémicycle
elle n'est pas voté je ne peux pas
penser ça debout aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous déposez
vous déposer une proposition de loi qui
finalement est similaire à celle que
nous avions déposé pour se dire les
choses
elle est complètement similaires nous ne
sommes pas comme vous nous sommes pas
sur des dogmes et nous allons voter
cette proposition de loi
parce que ce qui importe pour nous c'est
ce que les gens nous ont dit tout à
l'heure dans la rue lorsqu'avec ma
collègue laurence brûle laurence cohen
céline brulin et les membres de notre
groupe nous sommes allés devant la porte
du sénat voir ces associations et que
ces associations nous ont dit nous
espérons que nous allons voter cette
proposition de loi
parce que nous avons perdu assez de
temps alors oui nous avons perdu à 7 ans
et je regrette
que nous ayons perdu d'ailleurs deux ans
et demi puisque celle ci aurait pu être
adopté deux ans et demi mais comme dit
un ami à moi le passé est à neuf cas
c'est le présent est à 9 qui couve donc
pour rappel lâché 2 900 euros 70 par
mois faut-il le rappeler nos personne
l'a dit tout le monde sait que c'est
très peu et donc il nous faut
aujourd'hui voter nous allons le faire
parce que ce qui compte avant tout ce
sont ces gens qui sont en situation de
handicap qui n'ont que 902 euros et qui
malheureusement sont victimes des
revenus du conjoint puisqu'elles sont
pris en compte dans lâche donc voilà
s'est imposée merci monsieur oui merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je suis heureux de
pouvoir en cet instant exprimer les
raisons de mon vote
ma satisfaction notre satisfaction je
pense partagés sur l'ensemble des bancs
de voir adopter cette proposition de loi
qui regroupe une série de bonnes mesures
prenant en compte grâce à notre
rapporteur tous les cas de figure et
leurs conséquences qui avait été ignoré
par nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale ces précisions nécessaires
permettent une véritable autonomie
financière et ainsi une plus grande
dignité à nos concitoyens frappés de
handicap et ne pouvant de ce fait
exercer une activité professionnelle en
individualisant le calcul de l'âge nous
réaffirmons ainsi la primauté de la
solidarité nationale sur la solidarité
familiale ainsi que le principe
d'autonomie
ce qui est bien le fondement même de la
philosophie de cette allocation qui
n'est pas à compter parmi les minima
sociaux
quinze ans presque jour pour jour après
l'adoption de la grande loi sur le
handicap le 11 février 2005 comme cela a
déjà été rappelé l'adoption ces mesures
de justice sociale concrète était
attendue par les associations et nos
concitoyens j'en profite par extension
pour saluer la décision de ne pas diluer
la hache dans le futur revenu universel
d'activité comme cela était craint par
beaucoup et j'en faisais partie
compte tenu de ces avancées apportées je
souhaiterais bien sûr qu'en faveur de
cette proposition de voir je vous
remercie
merci la parole et à madame dindar
merci madame la madame la présidente
merci madame la ministre je crois en
votre action en faveur des porteurs de
handicap vous êtes venu à la réunion
vous avez visité un certain nombre de
structures la mdph mais aussi les
associations
je vous ai entendu dans toutes vos
interventions et je sais que vous avez
agi que vous agirez encore en faveur des
personnes porteuses de handicap
je connais votre implication et je suis
persuadé que vous êtes favorable à cette
proposition noir qui a été présentée
aujourd'hui par notre notre collègue et
je voudrais remercier le travail qui a
été fait par le rapporteur et puis
l'ensemble de la commission des affaires
sociales
vous vous rappelez certainement avoir
croisé ici même ahmed
ce jeune porteur de handicap qui était
donc en stage ici et tout naturellement
puisqu'il vit il partage sa vie avec une
personne porteuse de handicap
il vous a fait part de cette situation
et il vous a dit moi je ne suis pas un
homme qui va prendre les revenus de ma
conjointe mais je connais beaucoup
d'hommes qui le ferait et cette
situation va laisser surtout les femmes
en situation de grande précarité
je suis de celles qui ne crois
absolument pas que la hache est un
revenu minimum et qu'il y ait des
plafonds je suis donc pour la
désolidarisation dès la prise en compte
des revenus du conjoint ou de tout autre
pour la prise en compte de cette
allocation en faveur des personnes
handicapées
soyez donc madame la ministre encore
cette mini ce qui aide ceux qui ont
vraiment besoin d'un autre regard sur le
handicap
parce qu'effectivement chacun porte son
handicap c'est pour ça que je serais
favorable plus que favorable à ce que
cette ppl soit votée à l'unanimité dans
cette enceinte de l'assemblée des
merci n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote mais dans la
ministre vous souhaitez vous exprimer
merci madame la présidente
oui depuis quatre ans je me bats pour
les droits des personnes en situation de
handicap et permettez moi de rappeler
juste quelques droits nouveaux que nous
leur avons ouvert le droit de vote pour
les majeurs protégés sous tutelle pour
les remettre comme citoyens à part
entière
le droit à vie pour justement qu'il
n'est plus à prouver leur état de
handicap en permanence les droits à la
parentalité puisque les personnes en
situation de handicap
depuis le début de l'année peuvent avoir
900 euros dès la naissance d'un enfant
en situation d'handicap plus 1200 euros
des techniques
voilà des droits réels pourquoi parce
que je pense que ce sont des citoyens à
part entière et les faire sortir
aujourd'hui du droit commun de la
fiscalisation des revenus les faits
justement ne plus être des citoyens à
part entière
on ne peut pas en même temps demandé
d'être dans le droit commun est d'être
avoir des dérogations permanentes
je préfère les soutenir justement en
travaillant surtout l'accompagnement
nécessaire et suffisant avec justement
les départements et c'est ce que nous
faisons en transformant l'accompagnement
en créant le droit au logement
grâce à l'aide à la vie partagée je vous
rappelle aux 8000 euros financés par la
cnca à 80% pour les départements qui
nous rejoignent donc voilà une politique
efficace d'accompagnement qui soutient
la pleine citoyenneté des personnes en
situation de handicap
cessons de les regarder à travers le
handicap regard des noms comme la
citoyenneté et pour autant ils sont
vraiment c'est ce qu'ils nous demandent
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour cela que je
suis défavorable à votre texte en l'état
en revanche je suis extrêmement
favorable à travailler bien sûr avec les
départements dans un cadre pour faire
cesser justement ces silos essais et ses
limites d'âge parce que nous faut
travailler sur le parcours et sécuriser
les parcours des personnes en situation
de handicap bien je vais trop voir cette
proposition de loi portant diverses
mesures de justice sociale qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient elle est
donc adopté madame la présidente
catherine de roche vous souhaitez
prendre la parole oui merci madame la
présidente d'abord vous remercier madame
la ministre et même si nous savions nous
ne serions pas d'accord sur cette
proposition doit saluer en effet
l'action que vous menez depuis depuis
maintenant plus
leurs années au profit des personnes en
situation de handicap nous la
reconnaissons et nous sommes souvent
d'accord avec vous sur beaucoup de poids
cette proposition de loi elle est venue
en effet dans un contexte tout à fait
inédit qu'est celui en des pétitions
instituée par le président larcher qui
amène un nom sur lequel nous allons
faire une évaluation pascale gruny est
en charge de cette évaluation mais je
voulais remercier filet mouillée qui a
trouvé le bon équilibre entre un texte
et ça c'est une réponse un peu à nos
collègues du groupe communiste nous
n'avons pas repris le texte en l'état
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait un coût
important
ils avaient des effets pervers qui était
ce en effet de de faire des perdants
donc le texte a été retravaillé là à mon
sens trouver un bon équilibre
donc j'en remercie beaucoup filet
mouillé tous ceux qui soutiennent ce
texte est bien évidemment nos
administrateurs dont alexis qui a trahi
sur ce texte je vous remercie donc merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]